[Rires]
mathieu lâche pas des petites mélina
c'est moi qui parle pendant les
particuliers et on n'était pas là oui
j'ai été élu à l'unanimité des délégués
du personnel et des chroniqueurs veut
dire qu'à partir de maintenant je
deviens médias pas de mon bébé c'est
fini tu seras toujours mon bébé clueless
est sans contredit quelque chose de
changé et je peux te dire aussi quelque
chose mais quand tu te tiendra pas dans
quelques jours peut-être dans quelques
mois c'est tout mais tu vas te prendre
un saut sur la gueule un jour mon pote
ça à faire tout drôle
mathieu je te dis moi j'adore ça ben oui
les embrasse moi bah ouais bah ça doit
bien voilà
[Applaudissements]
là
la guerre ensemble pour une grande le
coup suite
bienvenue de la grève mais non le bisou
et et on va kidnapper naulleau devenue
la grêle est tombée je peux délégués du
personnel favorable à les convictions tu
parles on fête en famille ou un petit
truc quand même tunique l1 mathieu merde
il est par ailleurs assez romantique
bien sûr avec toi comme tu que j'ai fait
qu'ils amènent dans les rêves et vos -
mettez du chocolat demain
[Applaudissements]
les gars on est sur le cannet la
question s'il ya pas grand mère assise
banon allait notre année ou amis ma
famille n'est pas là mais la fin du show
c'est pas un beau geste en 2010 il ya
plein d'imagés la yale et airolo moga
y a le blues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d
deux touchés mais là les bouches comme
ça non mais ça va
aurez vous voyez vos lèvres à
l'extérieur et les livres qu'ils
n'avaient rien de mouiller lorsqu'il
s'est passée à l'est et alors chef ya eu
la barre ou parle ça conseil l'elysée